come Randall how do you make a statement
that causes people to think without
giving them angry with your position I
think you have to stun and even if I was
actually when I started a Californian
startup we spend time right from the
get-go thinking about you know how do we
delight customers we come out with
something innovative unique but also
what are the values we want to live
buying the company and the key key
message today actually evident is that
the soft stuff is hard core is it's the
hard stuff you know it's easy to talk
about values it's all over easy to wet
take another crazy example n rock 2000
their values was communication respect
integrity excellence Wow res about
makeup so I think the thing is then when
you take a stand back to your question
it's got to be congruent and consistent
with your values so you know if we got
so many great customers doing ethical
products we've got customers doing
really good health food Gemma price
supermarket just creates clean delicious
food with no chemicals and that's kind
of cool to the values of the product
that she's created so when when you see
issues out there that you think wow it
breaks my heart is inconsistent and it
just just it's a breach of my values ism
and deviates us from our moral compass
then you got to put your hand up and
call them out and it's the final thing I
say evidence i would encourage everybody
and you're like this that's why i love
you remembered a minus one when you
started your business when you're
sitting there put your business plan
together remember the anger the passion
the dreams you have that the thing how
you wanted to change the world for your
product with your service and how you
knew you could be better than anywhere
else and you've got to remember those
and rekindle those dreams cuz cuz
that'll keep you strong I love the
passion man I love like you pound the
table and the camera shakes cuz you got
a laptop it's great i love it I you know
for me for this one I think in
10th trumps everything uh I don't think
you should go out and purposely try to
offend people with your statement in
your vision what you're trying to do but
I just don't think like you should try
to avoid making people angry I feel like
no matter what you do someone's going to
get angry so I'm just going to get upset
and if nobody is upset with what you're
doing and you're plain life so safe that
you're not standing for anything
important you know I'm sure by Stephen
not going to die val is there are some
people who are angry about that but it
wasn't his intent to just make those
guys upset he's trying to do something
positive and so I think the intent
Trump's and not to worry so much about
the people who are hating on you and
saying that you know this is a bad
message so I don't worry about angering
people because I know that the intent is
always positive